there's a sense of urgency at this
Market in the Pakistani Port of Karachi
people are rushing to stock up on food
and essential supplies ahead of cyclone
beeperjoy
the situation can get real bad because
of the storm the prices May shoot up so
I'm buying Essentials like rice lentils
and other things for my family
people have been evacuated from their
homes along the Southeastern coastline
more than 70 schools are being used as
relief camps many here say they're
worried about their future
our concern is when the cycling is over
how will we feed our children if our
boats are gone if our Huts are also gone
we will be languishing with no resources
named after the Bengali word for
disaster
scientists expect it to make landfall
between mandvi in Western India and
Karachi in southern Pakistan bringing
thunderstorms and severe winds for the
next five days
small houses and slums as well as mud
houses and Tin houses may get damaged by
the storm there'll be tidal waves and
when the Cyclone Burrows through most
places will get very heavy rainfall a
few places may experience extremely
heavy rainfall as well scientists say
climate change is making tropical storms
more powerful
many people in India and Pakistan now
appear to be suffering the consequences
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera